here with reaction the host of
unfiltered dan bongino along with the
co-host of the five gerald rivera
geraldo you cannot deny
that what joe biden said in his
is
speech
in pennsylvania in philly with the red
background or if you're watching fake
news cnn a pretty pink background
what he said there is a lie
what he's been saying about i want to
fund the police is a lie his own vice
president supported a bail fund for
rioters in in minneapolis his own vice
president praised the lapd for defunding
the lapd
so what he's saying is untrue geraldo
this is rampant in the democratic party
they're coddling criminals and americans
are paying the price tell me where i
might be wrong
well i i don't disagree basically with
anything you have said i hate to
disappoint dan but i believe that uh you
know joe biden was guilty of the most
lazy stereotyping with that magger
republican
nonsense and i'm sure he regrets saying
it i hope he regrets it because it
certainly rebounded against him
the only disagreement i have with
duchonne is that you didn't mention one
other factor
and that's race you have these cities
detroit new orleans baltimore cleveland
where i am
memphis where two of these horrible
crimes have happened they are majority
african-american cities where
african-americans commit most of the
murders and the victims of those crimes
are also usually african-american black
people killing black people it's the
ghetto civil war i've been talking about
that i've been pleading with people to
please do something about the reason the
abduction
of the woman
on this show we have been scrolling the
names
that americans have never heard of
before of people shot shot and killed in
chicago we've been doing it geraldo
since
2009 that's a longer period of time than
most people work on cable tv
well i could say this unless we
recognize that this is the civil rights
issue of our time that we have to
recognize what is happening and do
something about it then we will watch
the the destruction the waste of lives
black
brown
white
that is absolutely intolerable how can
it be that joe biden makes a speech like
he did about mega republicans and not
mention the crime that plagues the the
inner city you know this is something
that we must deal with or we will lose a
generation
you know dan your background is very
unique nypd secret service what if this
guy last night in memphis yesterday in
memphis happened to turn out to be a
maga republican what about the reporter
that was killed by a democrat what if it
was a maga republican what would the
media how would they be reacting what
would the coverage be like if that was
the case
well i mean you you know the answer so
does the audience be on the front page
of the new york times they'd be calling
for investigations of
the save america pac or whatever uh it
would be collective attribution everyone
who voted for trump would be a
bloodthirsty serial killer but you know
the hypocrisy is boring it's not
hypocrisy sean i i've argued this
repeatedly on my show
it's hierarchy
this isn't hypocrisy for the left it's
not hypocrisy requires two standards
correct one for me and one for thee
there's one standard the standards is
kiss my ass i'm in charge and i'm a
leftist we're totalitarians and we abuse
power do you think the shay guavaras of
the world used to put people up against
the wall and murdered him we're thinking
about man this is hypocritical i
wouldn't do this to my allies they
didn't think about that one second
left this when they get when when the
guns work for the leftists they'll abuse
the power of force i mean think about it
they love the fbi right now the fbi has
become an enforcement arm of the
democrat party they have it's pure and
simple they love the fbi and yet they
hate law enforcement it was joe biden
himself who's on a digitally recorded
video you can see right now telling an
interviewer he's for removing funds or
reallocating funds away from the police
he's only changed his mind you just
accurately said it in a 60-day election
day conversion because he's afraid
they're going to get humiliated at the
polls and let me just say one more thing
as a former police officer and agent
there are two reasons there's a civil
war going on as heraldo describes it in
the ghetto one they elect democrats but
second you know it's amazing how our
government spends four trillion dollars
on shrimp running on treadmills and all
kinds of stupidity and they plea bargain
cases out left and right because they
say wow we don't have enough jails we
don't have enough prosecutors you spend
four freaking trillion dollars a year
you can't figure out how to get savages
off the street and put them in jail you
can figure out how to fund a shrimp on a
treadmill and how to put plexiglass up
in kids schools for kova that didn't do
jack squad but you can't pay for a
lawyer to put a bad guy in jail you're
witnessing the collapse of society
because of stupidity like this
really well said dan bongino and geraldo
and by the way this may be a record the
first time you're both on together and
didn't really have a big fight so we got
it i got it
tip my hat to both of you because
one evening of agreement anyway dan good
to see you geraldo thank you